probably going b5 there
at some point would have been pretty
dangerous for me
but i prevailed in the end
so i'm happy of course okay we'll go for
the old aliogens defense
taken g6 let's see what he's preparing
here
if anything
yeah bishop
mission c4 can go
i think you have a bishop e6
let's see what it does
just castling huh
okay 97
i don't remember your theory here so i'm
basically
improvising but one of the points here
is i want to
with going these bishop b6 since i want
to
possibly save on c6 that i can go c5
in one go at some point and
i might may have some tactics like if
if he had moved the
if he had moved the knight like knight
f3 maybe i could have gone knight
e3 win the bishop pair bishop c4 and
even though i'm
a bit behind in development i still just
need bishop g7
castles to get a good position so i was
not so worried about that
rookie one feels a bit soft to me um
okay i'm gonna take it and then i
think i'm gonna go bishop g7 because i
feel like
obviously the exchange sack is a very
typical theme but as long as i can
castle queensland the weakening
of my king is not as important and
thus it shouldn't be all that dangerous
um so i had an idea here
um knight c3 is not very attractive to
me
uh because knight c3 happens and then
um he gets to develop with tempo uh i
can't go bish
knight to e3 and then if he goes bishop
e5
check i go c6 i take he takes
and it bishops either bishop c3 uh
bishop e3 or
fv3 protecting d4 lego c5
now i've sucked upon but i
think i do get some positional
compensation
it is this too adventurous
for tuesday nights that is the question
okay whatever enough wasted time i'll
just castle
not like a normal kid
and um
yeah i have castle now but i didn't
think
that he was gonna suck in exchange
uh after he had lost the tempo
um i can go c5
not crazy about that move
okay let me
let me go for a5 instead um c4 is what i
was
kind of hoping for i
thought i had the opportunity to play
dynamically now
the idea is night before
and bishop
six is met by queen d1 followed by
knight takes c2
so i'm not sure if he's really in time
to consolidate
obviously if he wasn't time to take an
e6 and then protect c2
my position would be a wreck
positionally speaking
but i don't think he's in time and thus
i should be should be fine
if you'd gone c3 um instead of
a4 uh protecting against the threat
of a4 i wouldn't have been able to do
this
and i would have had to play you know in
a normal
slightly passive way instead
this way i'm pretty happy
um because the whole construction with
the bishop on g7
the knight on b4 and everything all of
it makes sense
as long as white doesn't get to play c3
and i don't really think
c3 is a is an attractive
option here i guess
i can just go i can just go knight d3 or
even better i go
queen b1 bishop d1 knight d3 and i
actually win
material because both c1 and e1 cannot
be protected
um so in general i think i'm
achieving some of my positional goals
here
and i have quite some pressure against
this queen side probably
knight c3 is the best move here uh then
i take on
beats b3 okay this is interesting
um okay i don't take back no automatic
moves
i take on c2 and
if he takes on f7 i will be upon down
but i'm not i'm not even remotely
worried about that his rook will be
poorly placed in a2 i will get rook f2d8
exploiting his somewhat
uh [ __ ] development and um
here as well i think just roof v8 and i
should be doing
perfectly fine if if i'd gone
for let's say night before his work
would have had an avenue
to into the game via d2 or e2
but now well he does get the rook into
the game but at least i gained some time
i think overnight d4
to create the threat against against e3
and if knight d2 i'll go rook c8
probably
and here i'll go bishop h6 i don't think
he can protect everything
so knight c4 i've taken take on v3
and i think i should be better
[Music]
um
yeah let's just go with d4 see what he
does
if this now i probably gotta trade
yeah it's probably probably going to be
able to make a draw here
okay rook c7 let's try and make a little
difficult for him
i'm obviously short in time but we're
playing an increment so it shouldn't be
a major issue
rook b3 is a good move protecting the
bishop on a3
and now i do have bishop c1 i feel like
he might
miss that
we'll take this one go e5
try and gain some space oh i missed rook
b5 now it's going to be a draw for sure
um yeah that was uh that was a bit
unfortunate
okay take
take an a6 e6
yeah this is pretty pretty clear draw
but i will i will obviously try and push
a little bit see
steam as i do have an extra part
okay i'll go e5
62
okay now rook d3 e3 is coming
not 100 trivial
pretty far from from it actually as the
knights you say knee who would not say
um oh s3 that was his idea
okay that was an unfortunateness
still
had rook before there maybe then he
would be able to trap my rook
okay okay six
series we'll go back with the king
and we're hoping that his king is
kind of shut off push h4
okay we'll push again
it's not immediately obvious to me that
this is a draw
okay i think we have to get the right
behind
king goes
still you cannot take because the pawn
ending is lost
so it's not it's not at all obvious
we'll go check take on f4 rook f3 and
now i win the game
it's a little reminiscent of the game he
won against
against maxim in the in in the
quarterfinals where he won
a completely drawn rook in them
upon up okay
two up that's a pretty good start